[Applause]
well hi there
welcome to down the middle this
particular episode is going to appeal to
the younger viewers out there on youtube
we are going to break the demographics
of this show i'm so pleased to be
bringing to you today very
young accomplished successful people in
my field eric basmejian is a founder of
ebp macro research and we've also got
with us vance barr's founder and wealth
strategist at your dedicated fiduciary
he helps people think outside the box
when it comes to how to run their money
and that's
that's hard to find these days so
gentlemen
thank you both for being here today this
is this hey this is my first like two at
once but i had to add you up to get to
my age so um but thank you for being
here and this sunny beautiful afternoon
in manhattan this is just fabulous i'm
excited for this talk
welcome thank you so much it's quite an
honor to be here i can't tell you how
long i've listened to your fed
commentary and you've done some of the
most legendary interviews in economics
that i've ever
seen so it's quite an honor to be able
to speak with you and to be here okay
cut i'm kidding i'm kidding
[Laughter]
vance we met on twitter we did you're
the first person i've ever met on
twitter who have actually wanted to meet
in person after meeting them on twitter
as opposed to blocking and muting them
that's right 1996 me was like don't go
on the internet uh you know 2016 me is
like let's make friends yeah and thanks
for having me it's a pleasure it worked
you come to the christmas party you're
married to a great woman um two great
kids so
and eric you're recently engaged can i
say that out loud yes you can
congratulations and you know every
single steakhouse in manhattan
we can talk a whole hour about that
but rather than do that
vance i'm going to start with you
you uh you became a little
disenfranchised shall we say with the
way that people
had been
increasingly trained
post
march 2009
to run money and
that caused you to break out on your own
so what is your philosophy
and what do people need to know about
the advice they're getting these days
and
what they should be on the lookout for
at oh i don't know economic inflection
points
i spent a decade traveling the country
full time consulting leading wealth
managers at wire houses independent
broker dealers reas and of course family
offices and i learned
way more than i ever bargained for in
that role and very specifically i was
going in to meet with
the
investment committee for these firms
to consult them on how to use
institutional money managers and i
started in this business with altegris
investments which really a brilliant
idea in my opinion
if you could go to names like sac john
paulson
citadel winton breven howard third point
and others
you could but if you didn't have the
minimums you could go through
us so we were a platform of feeder funds
and i remember back in 2007
sitting at this happy hour spot in la
jolla and watching all of these very
nice cars come up and these guys get out
and they have the great big breitling
watches oh yeah and i've never met a
stranger so i walk up to them and i go
what is it that you guys do yeah i'm
just gonna say it out loud strange or
danger with you okay keep going
we're loan originators i go oh like like
mortgage brokers well yeah i go okay uh
well that's great and said well don't
you own a house no i think i had 15 000
bucks ain't up at the time they go you
dumb dumb
the opportunity puts zero money down and
in three or five years you'll be making
more money just go buy a house and i go
yeah but what if i'm not making more
money because the
the core rate that the fed funds rate
was a five handle yeah so let's do the
math on that i would have to have at
least uh god back in the good old days
right right
and
i went what happens if i'm not and they
go no problem just turn around and sell
the house i went
how many of these are you guys doing oh
this is all we do
and i thought this is interesting and i
did not predict 2008 i did not see that
coming i figured that the economy might
be a bug in search of a windshield
and the rest of us know that story but
in that 10-year period daniel i got a
lot of exposure
in going into these different so-called
wealth management offices and learning
what they offer clients what they don't
offer clients and how many of them
manage money per the consensus right it
was so fascinating to me because in 2007
when i was calling on these offices
saying hey we offer this platform of
strategies that historically have hedged
against downside market volatility
no one cared
no there were there were advisors many
of whom were well known that said take
me off your list don't bother me again
fast forward to
april may june of 2009 many of those
same people were calling me going hey
we'd like you to come in and meet with
some of our clients and uh go ahead and
you know do the dog and pony show yeah
bring some polar fleeces and some golf
balls
and it gave me a really unusual insight
into not only how these firms operate
the different conflicts of interest that
they have how they manage money the
products that they use are they
proprietary in nature it's a big one
but it also
gave me insight into
the decision
processes that are employed by the
investment committees and i did that for
about a decade and a few life events
happened
and i decided to set out on my own and
you know one thing i've learned over the
years is that life is what happens to us
while we're implementing our plans
but to the point in 2009
we entered into what i believe was a
paradigm shift in investing
that paradigm shift was the transition
into qe driven momentum driven
passive investment driven you know the
whole zerp world the teen all these
acronyms that we hear
and few of us knew that at the time
because we thought well the fed is doing
what's
believed to be in the best interest of
the public
and
here we are today and so we have
this momentum-driven world and i don't
know is active still alive
if it is it's it's still quickly dying
let's put it that way
now you at the time
were at nyu i want to say yes when the
world was ending it was a little bit i
was a little i was still in my tail end
of my high school career but i was going
to did i mention a younger demographic
okay here we are keep going yeah so
the way that it happened for me was i
was i was at nyu studying economics
and i took a course called financial
crises which was a history of all the
financial crises and
it resonated with me very deeply because
there were a couple of things one is
that they happened with irregularity
that all of us in our lifetime were
going to experience at least a couple of
these things right well you you me but
not janet yellen yeah that's right and
and then the other thing is that when
they did happen it was all that mattered
right so for example you could be
sitting there in 2007 in one of these
wealth management offices
or at a uh bottoms up shop and you could
have done the best bottoms-up analysis
on coke versus pepsi but it really
didn't matter when when a financial
crisis happened right so it didn't make
sense to me to have an investment
framework that didn't have some element
of understanding
the the symptoms of buildups or causes
of these events
so all of these financial crises had
some
element of um
excesses in in debt right
so
that set off uh sort of an obsession in
understanding these debt dynamics and
debt deflation and demographics the two
factors that i feel are most important
to to understanding these long-term
trends
so i started to read everything that
there was
uh on the subject which brought me to to
one of what i think is your greatest
interviews which was with dr lacy hunt
who's probably the best on this subject
that we have he is a legend um
and uh fast forward i graduated and i
actually was able to jump straight to
the buy side and i worked at a quant
shop
which was not in the macro space but i
learned a lot of programming and some
good stuff there
and it also gave me some sensitivities
to
the short-term nature of portfolio
managers right so you can have a great
you can have a great long-term thesis
and try and understand these financial
crises that may happen every 10 years
but everyone's worried about what's
going to happen this quarter right yeah
so i knew that there was that you had to
bridge the gap between the the long-term
secular trends that may contribute to
excesses and more short-term
uh focused research which led me to
studying business cycle experts like uh
jeffrey moore
and jeffrey moore had a concept called
these growth rate cycles so these cycles
and growth that happen within a business
cycle right so from 2009
until 2020 when we had coveted that was
one long business cycle expansion but
you know as well as anyone danielle we
had a a crisis in 2012 in europe and
then we had a cyclical upturn we had oil
fell to 20 a barrel in 2016. and that's
for a recession exactly exactly we it
was a quasi recession some people called
it right then we had another big upturn
and then we had the trade war slow down
right all of these were independent
cyclical events so i thought wow there's
a lot of really prime research to be
done on these growth rate cycles and
having and at this fund you'll know as
well as anyone danielle that
the consensus wall street research only
goes one way
right and there are these 18 month
cycles two year cycles that are turning
all the time some of them end in
recession some of them don't so i
thought i looked out there and i didn't
think that there was really anyone that
was putting together these secular
trends and these cyclical trends and i
thought that there was a great
opportunity to to provide some research
there so that's sort of how i got
started doing what i'm doing
so
um
both of you have really employed social
media to your benefit
vance
are you just twitter are you other
platforms i think you're linkedin
how is that um
how has that affected your career
trajectory
since
call it the first decade versus since
then so i'm a little older than i look
and social media to me is sort of um an
arbitrary forced thing right
i was strongly encouraged to join
twitter
rewind back to when i founded my firm
seven years ago today by the way well
well congratulations thanks yeah you
know i think we made it right
but well your socks certainly think so
we'll get to that okay perfect um i
called the chief marketing officer that
i had worked with who was an absolutely
wonderful soul and i asked her how do i
get my message out you know i have this
knowledge up here about what many of the
family office raa wirehouse teams don't
do particularly with respect
to advanced planning
how do we keep as much money in the
estate as possible how do we foster
familial unity things like family
heritage statements people go what is
that yeah like the things that
ultimately matter most to humans and i
want to take what's up here from my
experience in consulting financial
advisors on how to invest for high net
worth and alternative families
and convey that message in a meaningful
way and she said you have to hire mark
rose of finn squared which i did which
was a game changer for me for two
reasons one i got a website out of the
deal
and
two
websites are tricky they are they are
and they can be time consuming as well
and two he said you have to get on
this fintwit thing i'm like
i'm on twitter excuse me i'm on linkedin
i'm on facebook the last thing i need is
another time drain and social media
platform and he goes no i don't think
you understand you have to join twitter
because that's where all the financial
journalists
you know hang out and share ideas and so
on and so forth
and he
it was so interesting the day after we
had sold our beach place and moved
inland in san diego
he calls me he said i have jeff benjamin
of investment news he's ready to talk to
you about alternative investments i went
great when he goes right now i'm like
i'm on four and a half hours of sleep i
got boxes stacked up there's no way he
goes when jeff benjamin of investment
news
is ready to talk
and we got on the phone and i was
exhausted and it was a very
to my fault awkward conversation
and it was a pretty brief seven to eight
minute conversation
and i couldn't talk about some of the
the product related questions that a lot
of financial journalists naturally ask
about because the compliance alligators
will start chomping at the tail feather
right
count your blessings not being part
anyway um in any event
so
i had heard through the rumor mill that
jeff benjamin was going to be attending
the schwab conference in san diego
knowing that he was in the marines once
marine always marine and thank you jeff
and everyone for your service
my grandfather who was a marine
made a figurine that i have at my desk
and i brought that with me because jeff
agreed to give me a 10-minute
coffee conversation at the schwab
conference
and we sat down and i pulled it out of
my briefcase and i said i just want you
to know i really appreciate what you've
done for this country
i am as patriotic as they come
and that 10-minute conversation evolved
into a 90-minute interview where i
spilled my heart to him
on what i thought the public needs to
know about the inner workings of not
only the financial services industry but
also the areas particularly the planning
areas where so many wealth management
firms and teams don't bring value
looking at tax returns how can you do
what's in the best interest of the
client
without a deep understanding of the tax
return what about the estate planning
and i can save that for later but that
relationship formed quickly and jeff
benjamin of investment news is
ultimately the one who introduced me to
so many of the financial journalists and
that's why i'm active on twitter it's
for the idea sharing and the value
content creation for the public so my
takeaway here is
is your philosophy on nobody ever being
a stranger no one i've never met a
stranger it doesn't matter if it's a
bozo on the bus or a billionaire in a
bentley everyone's the same
this is wise wise wise guidance because
people ask me all the time
what's the best thing to do with outside
of your career and my answer is always
sales
you've got to start off in sales in one
shape or form because in life no matter
where you land and what you're doing
even if it's being a great macro
economist you're selling you're selling
constantly absolutely so
so you were
you you have a you have a unit platform
because i mean all i know of you is on
twitter but then i'm yes i've been told
i need to find this thing called
instagram i know i'm on it i just
anyways
so so twitter is my my big platform i
mean i have epb macroresearch.com but
but my big presence of gaining uh
new followers or spreading my message is
really is really through twitter that's
that's the best medium for me and
um social media is is the best that the
world has to offer and the worst that
the world has to offer right
you know it's it's certainly you know if
you ask me it's one of my favorite
places to be but if you ask my fiance
it's terrible right because i'm on it
all the time um so it's
it's become i've heard that yeah right
yeah
it's an hour of trying trying to hide
somewhere kids don't pair it like this
right in line at the grocery store you
gotta just make sure you get yeah you
know what's going on um
but it's become a place that we all have
to be right it's where all the eyeballs
in the world are i mean you look at the
big five companies i think i read a
study recently that the big five or six
companies occupy over 90 percent of
people's day-to-day time you think about
you're either on your phone your
computer
every single thing that you do of your
waking hours it's all controlled by five
people which are these social media
platforms basically so if you're looking
for business growth it's an essential
place to be you really can't you know
you pick your platform it's youtube or
twitter or instagram
but you have to be there because that's
where the eyeballs are and it's a
delicate balance between trying to
extract all the great parts of twitter
or social media in terms of leveraging a
following but also learning new
information and then trying to resist
the temptation to be there all the time
which is something i think that we're
all trying to work on every day i think
my eyeball's just back in my head again
but you know the best twitter advice i
ever got was always provide a picture
and i think that's probably because
fintwitt is dominated by men i really
just said it out loud
but that that was some of the best
advice i ever got was always show a
graph
right don't just throw the words out
there unless they're like words of some
central banker um but always always
share a graph you've got great graphs so
tell me a little because
when i first saw your research i'm like
this stuff is rich i mean it's and
you think completely outside the box
do you think that's because you never
went over to the dark sell side
i think that having the freedom to to
operate and just say what's on my mind
at any time is a huge competitive
advantage because i speak to some people
that are
um
really limited in terms of what they say
they say man i would love to say x y z
but i'll never get that through my
compliance officer and i'm like well
that's a horrible way to operate right
yeah and and if we're all trying to find
the right answer here it never made
sense to me why some things would be off
limits right oh sell side research is
it's censored yeah and that it goes back
to the uh one of the comments i made
earlier that it all seems to go one
direction right you never you can
usually get away with anything that's
going in a bullish or positive direction
but it's the bearish stuff that
may may not go with with the consensus
narrative right well
so i recently had a conversation with
randy forsythe who at the beginning of
his career he had like four years at
merrill lynch back when we still had
mother merrill with us and it's funny
because all these years later you're
saying what he said occurred in the
1970s that you could never have a cell
order for a stock the neutral meant sell
and that everything else was pretty much
buy and it's just incredible that we've
gone through all of these generations
and yet
sell side research really hasn't evolved
to the benefit of the client it's
evolved i mean they make a lot of money
so it's important yeah big benefit of
them
but but getting back to clients i mean
how do you
how do you communicate to to clients to
look further out over the horizon in an
environment in which people are so
focused on
you know where did bitcoin close well i
take that back bitcoin does not close
sorry big boo-boo
um that's 24-hour exactly exactly it's a
24-hour asset class i don't think a lot
of people though understand that you're
right you know
someone yeah another reason to be on
twitter on the weekends right someone
out there just went oh it's open 24 7.
great the casino stays late right i'm
just gonna hook myself up to coffee
right now and never go to sleep hey wait
the casino doesn't close at four on
friday exactly casino yeah
that's a good way to put it
but so how do you convey to people to
calm down step back
look out over the horizon not try and be
at that very precipice of the next
hottest thing
when markets get volatile
i get very few calls
and that's for two reasons one it's
because most of the
50-ish families that are served by
our firm
have been through capital market cycles
and they understand and secondarily i
tell them i will proactively communicate
with you when i'm worried start worrying
and and i mean that sincerely i will let
you know when things are very concerning
to me i will come to you with solutions
because what's the point in just
complaining about a problem or a
potential problem
and in the meantime
mrs jones until i actually am worrying
go out and live your life run your
business spend time with the grandkids
spend time with your kids go live life
to the fullest
because that's what ultimately matters
and i want people to understand that the
goal
is to live an enriched fulfilling life
and my own life experiences have
instilled that in me and i've just you
know made it my raison d'etre if you
will
so um so the clients get to unplug but
you don't
yes and you know let's go back to the
covet sell-off it was the fastest equity
sell-off in history no
since 1933 but yes yes
carry the two yes that's right pop quiz
she knows her stuff yeah you'll never
win a pop quiz against yeah yeah not a
competition yeah but
it was the fastest in
recent memory and the fastest for
uh you know even the the folks at our
firm the clients of our firm that are in
their late 70s to mid 80s
and it happened so fast and
there were a handful of folks that
called not because they were worried
about
equities going to zero or anything like
that they called to go how are you doing
how is this impacting you as a human
being what are you doing to find zen
and it was very touching when i got
those calls
but
when volatility shows its head there's
opportunity and we took action
what do you make of uh the division
of 2021 um
a lot of very successful investors were
publicly derided for having large cash
positions
and i mean they were really taken to the
woodshed you know this person's like
they clearly they've
passed their expiration date take them
out to pasture
and
and then things get bumpier and bumpier
and bumpier and all of a sudden who's
got money for opportunities and who
doesn't i mean dry powder
yeah
we live in
up until
it might be a paradigm shift again right
now right we've been in this qe driven
passive driven
um let's look at 401k plans what happens
you have to now opt out
right so you get thrown in the qdia you
get thrown into the target date fund
it's passive passive passive
and
in the zerp driven world in the qe
driven momentum driven
flow driven environment
active management particularly when you
look at some of the the well-known hedge
fund managers that have gone
i can't yeah right
um it's a pretty difficult environment
and
there's much to be debated with respect
to
whether or not we might be at a paradigm
shift now if rates go up you know let's
say we have inflation that's high
but
it ends up going down to an above
average level of inflation historically
when that's happened that's been
a windfall if you will for
certain types of value equities
look at the alligator jaws between
growth and value
since qe started are they about to shut
i don't know stay tuned for more time
will tell well
let's ask a fundamental question eric
you know
does the fed have the same optionality
that
that ben bernanke had to to launch qe
that that jay powell had in
2018 20 2019 to launch not qe is that
optionality there yeah well it's going
to be extremely difficult for them to
make the same pivots of the past because
obviously of this crazy high inflation
rate that we have right now
um one one point that i want to you know
touch on that that you were just saying
is
while the central banks have
exerted a huge thumb on the scale
when we look at these growth rate cycles
we do find that asset prices are still
very correlated to these growth rate
cycles that happen
for example but
what is different is how long it takes
assets to react and then how quickly
they panic
but
when we look at the 2015 into 16
slowdown huge equity market correction
when we look in 2012 huge equity market
correction
2018 you know the trade war slowdown
which in my opinion was not really
related to the trade war we had interest
rate cuts we had you know equity market
correction so we still do see asset
prices following these growth rate
cycles although there has been a lot of
distortion that's come in in various
different places so i just want to make
the note that even though they're
exerting a heavy hand on the situation
when we look at these growth rate cycles
they still do drive in my opinion the
majority of the move i don't think that
central banks have taken over into into
a realm where nothing matters anymore i
think that the data suggests otherwise
but going to your question about the
about the potential pivot here it's
going to be incredibly difficult because
we don't have the inflation numbers that
incorporate these uh russia and ukraine
situation yet which could put even
further upward pressure on food prices
and energy prices so we may not have
seen the peak in uh year-over-year cpi
inflation yet but what is interesting
danielle is that long-term inflation
expectations like five-year five-year
forwards are reluctant to push to this
new high they're sort of still granting
the fed this credibility that
if you guys really raise like you say
you are
we may have a sharper economic slowdown
and that may keep
inflation i mean i feel like you know on
longer-term inflation expectations i
feel like there's a three percent
ceiling exactly you can't you just can't
get past it and that has to do i think
with these secular conditions that we
were talking about earlier so one of my
biggest
one of my biggest struggles
myself uh with my own macroeconomic
thesis is it's very difficult to square
the
visible slowdown because we had consumer
confidence sour this is prior to
february 24th when when putin marched in
into ukraine
many indicators were already slowing
yeah prior to and yet
it's so hard to square that with what's
going on in the labor market right now
what what are your
do you see anything in the weeds that
that's telling you something different
than the
jolts data which
which lacy hunt himself finds to be
somewhat questionable yeah it's funny i
i actually uh of all the data series
that i look at the jolt series is not
one that's in my main uh bucket of
indicators um i look at all economic
data in in rate of change terms or in
geeky math terms and second derivative
terms right so what's gay calculus right
so
the growth rate accelerating or
decelerating right and
what we saw was we had this huge drop in
all economic data into covet and then we
had this rebound right and
when we look at what i would call
coincident economic indicators which
sort of marks the economy which would be
employment consumption income and
industrial production
all four of those indicators peaked in
growth rate terms in either march or
april so employment and growth rate
terms actually peaked in april of 20 20
21 2021 right about six percent
employment growth and that's cooled to
about four percent so four percent is
still a very high number right but in in
rate of change terms it's it's declining
and when we look at leading indicators
of employment
uh weekly manufacturing hours worked
they did increase in in the last report
but it's been a sharp slowdown right for
the last six or seven months which tends
to foreshadow a continued drop in in the
growth rate of of that employment and
the other thing that
i would mention is that
as the inflation rate sticks higher
the real growth number will stick lower
right this inflation doesn't create
magical nominal growth all this
inflation will do is steal from real
growth right so if if nominal is six and
inflation comes in higher that's just
gonna detract from real growth and i
think what a lot of people misunderstand
is that real growth is more synonymous
with um like unit volume or production
volume right so if we have this super
high inflation number and the atlanta
fed number for q1 is basically at zero
and we have unit volumes that are
falling close to zero well what does
that mean you need less production you
need less employment and then that
cycles back to less income and then you
get this what we call a vicious economic
cycle
where old adverse feedback exactly where
where lower real income feeds to lower
consumption which leads to lower
employment and less production and that
cycle feeds on itself the opposite of a
virtuous economic cycle so those those
examples are kind of how i square what
what is seemingly a quote-unquote tight
labor market the last point is that even
though this is reportedly the tightest
labor market we've ever seen in the
history of whatever
we still can't generate positive real
wage gains
so that's that's something that doesn't
square with the narrative right if the
market was so tight and companies you
know couldn't find labor and they were
willing to do anything they're banging
on doors to get labor
pay a wage rate above the rate of
inflation right but they can't do it
either their margins are too compressed
or
it's not in their best interest to to
acquire new labor and expand output so
there are some discrepancies going on
with this very tight labor market
phenomenon so i'm going to i'm going to
give give you a pop quick quick pop quiz
question um which is hard to say
you're up yeah
um
is the supply chain disruption over
uh
well
i i would say it's it's really difficult
to answer that i would say i don't know
well i mean we've had i mean your your
average
freighter in los angeles has gone from
13 and a half days to two days to get
unloaded right and your your regional
fed surveys are suggesting right that
right inventories are rising exactly i
would say so because it's an impossible
question to answer by the way yeah
exactly not fair it's a trick question
i'm off the hook uh but if if you i
wrote a note uh before the russia
ukraine
event and there were as you were
suggesting a significant amount of
signals that were suggesting the peak in
inflation may may be in right we were
seeing supplier delivery times come down
inventories were rising as you said
inflation expectations were coming down
um other leading indicators of inflation
like the producer price index
core producer price index was starting
to come come down in growth rate terms
but then the russian ukraine event
happened which threw a whole nother kink
in the supply chain which now makes it a
little bit more unpredictable because
now we'll have to wait for all this new
data to come in to see what happened to
the supply chain i know uh empire fed
manufacturing for march was recently
released which showed supplier delivery
times ticked up again yep the the
business activity was terrible
but supplier delivery times continue to
get extended so i think we'll have to
readdress the situation i know uh all of
us who have tried to call the peak in
inflation have been you know slapped in
the face a couple of times with these
rolling supply chain disruptions but uh
i would say that the signs were in that
it was starting to ease i think we'll
have to readdress once we get more
information
so uh
former down the middle guest dennis
mcgill
he adheres to both of your philosophies
about the rate of change
so
how vance how do and
his bottom line is that the growth rate
of the population has been declining for
years
and that that's what matters most we
talked about demographics
is destiny yes it is and it has slowed
to the extent that the national
association of realtors the largest
lobby in the country hello
their their estimate that we need 6.8
million homes built is just
ridiculous compared to
maybe the 1 million deficit that is
actually out there according to dennis
mcgill's math and he's he's really done
the granular work that needs to be done
and so as as hard as it is to conceive
we may be
at an inflection point finally for the
baby boomer generation
so how do you help plan
a portfolio when we may be approaching
this great shift
out of equities and presumably into
fixed income and what that regime
change is going to
how that's going to affect how you plan
because there are
75 million of them
10 000 baby boomers are retiring today
in this country
it's a big number it's a huge number
right
and
on the demographics equals destiny idea
to piggyback on that
in the working age population in high
income earning developed nations and
china has plateaued and is projected to
go down over the next 25 years
so that shortage in workers i would
argue might and i emphasize might mean
additional
wages or higher wages can be demanded
ergo some level of inflation right
you're the
macro
macroeconomist
excuse me um but in any event if we have
that paradigm shift
and you know we look at a 60 40
portfolio
how we in the 60 so in the stock
portfolio how we use different types of
equities in different sectors
can largely become much more important
if we enter into an environment where we
do have an above average level of
inflation on the heels of the last 10
years and what i was talking about
earlier is it's not like the fed has
driven markets entirely for the last
decade but when we are in a rate where
interest rates are at zero
right the fed takes its balance sheet to
9 trillion the federal reserve and the
treasury have a shotgun wedding which i
dubbed treasury on twitter
good one right
it's an environment that we have to
understand we have an entire generation
of investors right now today who have
only known
zero interest rate policy and balance
sheet
policy for their their entire investing
careers whether they're in the
professional world like us or those
self-directed investors fixed income
becomes very important what is the
average effective duration
of the bonds in that portfolio what's
the credit quality and this is nothing
new to
you know those of us who have been in
the industry for some time but it
becomes really important because
selection is key
so it sounds like uh it sounds like
dividends are going to become more
important as a factor of time
my view is that tax returns should drive
all prudent planning for someone because
let's say you go to a medical specialist
what does that medical specialist almost
always ask for
your general health history from your gp
in my role i need the equivalent of that
which is you know the last three to five
years of tax returns from the cpa
and you know a typical client we don't
have a usual model
so i got out of the business of uh
giving free advice
you know it was interesting in my former
career when i was you know it was me on
one side of the table and uh the
investment committee at whatever firm or
you know for whatever team on the other
side of the table with an average age of
72 or 68
and then there's me right and we're
talking about the yield curve steep in
our trade or theta bleed right or some
of these things right and i thought oh i
know uh the typical
potential client would love to know
all of these things that i can talk
about the typical client doesn't want to
know that you go into that and they
leave the husband gets asked by the wife
what was he what was that guy talking
about
i don't know honey it's just some
economic stuff maybe we go to the guy
down the street who sent us that little
invitation for a steak dinner and
something about guaranteed income in
retirement right
it happens all the time yeah um
and so
really understanding
the things that make
the typical client tick and how to bring
maximum value
uh much of that information is available
on a tax return because let's say
they're in the
highest tax bracket
what you do in a non-retirement in a
taxable portfolio
read qualified dividends can become much
more important here's a common case so
someone will have
a financial advisor or broker whatever
you want to call this person
and we'll meet and our model is you're
never going to get asked to move your
money to us ever
for a flat cost we look at tax returns
estate planning documents
all insurance policies and i mean all
insurance policies of course investment
accounts and ultimately a household
balance sheet if they have one and it's
our job to figure out where the planning
gaps are and in almost all cases clients
go i have a great cpa i have a great
estate planner i've been with my you
know advisor at two name firm or however
many acronyms firm for years and you
know the trust company is going to take
over when i transition to the spiritual
side and i go okay that's great
i've spent a lot of time in my life
consulting these folks let me see what
we might be able to determine
and at the end of that process we give a
full report with key findings and in all
but one case
every one of those folks has turned at
the end of that and gone
i didn't know what i didn't know you now
know everything about me and what needs
to be done what would you charge to
manage the assets and just do all this
stuff
and that was a model that took me three
years to figure out but that's really
when the firm started to grow so it's a
holistic approach very much so and i
have to talk with the cpa i have to talk
with the estate planner
and to bring it back to answer the
question i bet the guy who's at the
insurance company i don't want to talk
to you at all
i'm not that popular among many of those
folks
but think about it in medicine
licensed doctors have to take the
hippocratic oath that does not exist in
our industry no that bothers me no first
do no harm is it doesn't exist in in
your industry sure as hell doesn't exist
at the fed
right you mean the federal reserve has
not been the beacon of moral light
i mean that was that was something we
talked about constantly at the fed was
during the heat of the crisis was
first do no harm do you not understand
there's going to be consequences i mean
thomas honig has been really vocal
in the past six months or so in saying
you know i was a lone voice
that dissented descent at dissented and
i remember at the time i was like the
main i was like go tom go
and you know
it's
hindsight looking back i just
eric i don't think central bankers
appreciate how much they've monkeyed
with economic cycles
yeah i mean so one of the things that
they've really had an impact on is
compressing the spread in my opinion and
in the corporate market right which
which may have so so what i would what i
would concede is that
directionally the cycle still exerts a
big influence over where we're going but
when the cycle is is moving
higher let's say let's say we're in a
cyclical upturn
their added liquidity
provides an even additional compression
which causes things to get into these
crazy valuations or sort of fuels the
excesses that may have already been
starting to build it just comes in and
it blows things completely out of
proportion so
define compression define spread
compression please right okay so so the
spread between uh corporate bonds or or
or bonds that have that have risk and
and treasury bonds right so as that
spread compresses uh and investors are
looking for for yield it may force them
to go further out on the risk spectrum
or trade bonds for equities or or do
something that they may have not
otherwise have done right those
if that availability for yield was a
little bit higher it also distorted some
of the risk that we're seeing right so
one thing that they that they do and
this goes to how they may be adversely
impacting everyday people is you know
someone will say
well i need yield so i'm gonna go buy
this stock that has a six percent
dividend yield or a seven percent
dividend yield while the treasury rate
is two and they're not putting together
that hey if something is yielding three
or four times the risk-free rate that
that might mean that there's quite a bit
of risk in there
but we're just you know the big the big
uh one that i'm looking at is you
remember in the early uh 2010s was this
big mlp
uh phenomenon oh yeah there were there
were huge yields attached to these mlps
that people rushed into and then the
cycle turned oil went down they didn't
end too well but that may have been a
phenomenon that the fed created from
from chasing yield
you know if you look at the sector of
the corporate bond market that has
benefited the most in terms of borrowing
costs post covid it is the triple b
sector right it is that rung right above
junk that credit rating right above junk
oh please it's not junk let's call it hi
okay
yeah
milken himself would call it right but
jay powell said you may not call it junk
and
it's it it it's those kinds of events
when you see the marriage of
the fed and the treasury and you get
treasury
it's those kind of moments that
make it that much more difficult to plan
out portfolios
and
because you you have this artificial
element
that is kind of corroding the process
so i don't envy
people like you i just i just advise
people like you
and many of us are happy to listen and
our devout followers of yours we've
talked a lot about passive versus active
and when it comes to the composition of
a portfolio i have a few thoughts to
share
one is it's not either or in my view
because data drives decisions right
people go well i'm all passive or i'm
all active i go why
first of all it depends on the type of
account if it's a retirement account we
need a qualified account then we're not
taxed until we take money out right if
it's a non-qualified or non-retirement
account the investment decisions that
are made and the actions that are are
taken in that account really matter
because it's ultimately going to have an
impact on that calendar year's tax
return
so we will commonly have a family on
board and they've had a financial
advisor who may have put them into you
know expensive very tax inefficient
stock mutual funds in their
non-retirement account there's still a
ton of money inactive people forget that
like there's a ton of money in actively
managed mutual funds we all know the
names of these companies right but
they'll come on board and i have a
software that will convert the average
cost basis which is how it's reported on
the statement to a tax lot specific cost
basis let's go back over to the tax
return is there any charitable
intent is there any history of a
philanthropic donations for a family
well if we have a tax lot that was sold
to them
in
1999 right
a tech fund right yep and the
appreciation on that particular tax lot
is hundreds of percent or even more
we can use those positions
to
donate to charity through one or more
vehicles right let's get a tax deduction
if they have that intent
and maybe just maybe because the capital
gains and the dividends that are
reinvested in these mutual funds they
might have tax lots that are at a loss
so we can go in and look at what tax
lots are down short term offset those
with
sales of short-term tax lots that are up
so it's a net neutral from a tax
standpoint same thing with long-term
loss
or long-term gain tax lots right and
when we look at the position or the
composition pardon me of a portfolio
if passive for a particular market
large cap growth i'm just coming up with
a for a particular sector
historically has outperformed active and
is cheaper and is more tax efficient
key driver they're attacks efficient
then it doesn't matter what my opinions
are with respect to active and passive i
like both it just depends right and that
data drives how those
allocations are satisfied in a portfolio
all right i'm going to have to
get you in touch with my cpa and others
i love nerdy now with cpa it's big time
the typical cpa goes you want tax
returns why and they go because
it's not that the tax tails should wag
the financial planning or investment dog
but if the goal
is to minimize unnecessary taxes let's
say you have a million dollars in a
non-retirement portfolio
meaning a taxable account that's in all
expensive tax and efficient mutual funds
let's say you went to
a two-name trust company who said we'll
manage the money for 50 basis points by
the way we're going to put it in our
proprietary mutual funds okay with that
with huge fees right right so let's look
at the tax drag i look at the schedule d
on the tax return and i can see all of
the
the tax drag that's showing up on that
tax return there are solutions for that
and the public has no idea
now they do
[Laughter]
let's let's go back to
a subject that has become
such a hot issue on twitter and
maybe if they don't hear it from lacy
hunt maybe if they hear it from somebody
your age
they can finally understand that it is
the growth of the money supply not the
stock of the money supply
that is the major determinant why is it
so difficult to communicate this without
getting you know people hating me for
like a 24 hour span right i i actually
put on twitter a couple days ago that i
hadn't seen a lot of charts and money
supply growth lately right it just
when it's going the other direction you
know um
we don't hear about it a lot and then
everyone when when money supply growth
goes up we call it printing money but if
the money supply growth starts to
contract
are we going to call it destroying money
i don't know i don't think we are right
but um
but yeah so it's the same concept as
when we're looking at regular growth a
lot of people that i speak with
have a difficult time just understanding
that the growth rate slowing is what's
important not
um is the growth rate good or is the
growth rate bad because at the end of
the day that's an opinion right if i
said to you danielle or vance economy x
is growing at five percent is that good
or bad
you have no idea because if it grew if
it grew at ten percent the year before
it could be a national emergency right
if it grew at at one percent that would
be the best growth rate the economy has
ever seen same thing with the money
supply right so if we had conditions
that were created by 40 money supply
growth and now we have 10 money supply
growth you can't say well that's still a
lot of money supply growth because it's
relative to the conditions that were
created at 40 money supply growth so to
your point we're now seeing the money
supply growth
uh decline pretty dramatically and if
the fed is able to execute on these
quantitative tightening plans that they
have outlined we're likely to see an
outright contraction in money supply
growth we're seeing a near contraction
in the monetary base as of the last
report so that would be
radically different conditions than what
were created over a year and a half ago
so with all these things it's it's the
rate of change you know another example
is is you know if you're going 100 miles
an hour is that fast or slow well if
it's a car it might be fast if it's an
airplane it might be slow right right so
it all depends on where you were coming
from and where you're going yeah the
most animated that i heard lacey get
recently was he was he was like have you
seen the h8 and i'm like no sir yeah i
haven't please please tell me
have you seen other liabilities and
other deposits and liabilities the
growth rate slowed down to 2.2 percent
i'm like
i hear you amen yeah but but people i
don't know why people just they refuse
to look at that and so sticking on this
on this theme
7.1 percent to a rounding error
i mean if you look at where we were in
terms of fourth quarter gdp
and what's expected right now and by the
way my former macroeconomic advisors ben
herzon
he's got my favorite gdp model on the
street you know he's down to you know to
also a rounding error for the first
quarter
that's one hell of a delta yeah in terms
of in terms of the rate of change that's
a wicked slowdown yeah and it's a wicked
slowdown i would have never said that
but i i just yeah and all right it's
it's
in my opinion it's
primarily coming from what we're you
know to put it mildly a collapse in real
income right we keep seeing that the
wages are the highest ever and people
are posting these numbers of atlanta fed
wage trackers at six percent it's the
highest ever like we just got a nine
percent or an eight percent inflation
number so real income is going in the
wrong direction right and when when real
income collapses then what happens to
consumption right consumption can't stay
elevated if real income declines and you
know we talk excess savings that's
that's been the the most uh irritating
phrases
yeah that one is coming to save the day
really driving me nuts but you know i
don't know where all this excess savings
has gone because the last report was six
point four percent personal savings rate
the lowest since 2013 right
so as lacey points out this stimulus
came and it went in record time it
seemed to fade uh in a matter of
quarters and now here we are with
negative real income growth or soon to
be depending on what measure you use
retail sales coming out soon going to
show
you know growth rate in that you know
one two three percent range in real
terms um so
now we're at a situation where like you
said huge delta on the slowdown
potential recessionary conditions where
the federal is now going to tighten
so that's going to create
it is creating a volatile cocktail and i
would expect that to continue especially
as we walk closer and closer to this uh
recessionary window which i outline with
with several criteria and in my view
we're not we're not quite there yet but
we could be there as the data comes in
the next couple of months so what um
what are these signposts what are your
red flags so first thing that i would
look at is is the growth rate declining
or is the growth rate accelerating if
the growth rate is accelerating you
can't be going into a recession right
that is true so that's that's sign
number one is the growth rate declining
absolutely yes right and then is the
growth rate sufficiently close to zero
right because if we had a
massive economic shock a year ago where
the growth rate in the economy was seven
percent you can't put the economy in a
recession because the shock would have
had to knock 700 basis points off of
growth it would have been you know like
a nuclear bomb or something like that or
a coveted lockdown something like that
right right but but barring but barring
that there's no you know an oil price
spike at seven percent real growth won't
cause a recession right so the growth
rate has to be sufficiently close to
zero at which point a shock can can
knock a couple hundred basis points off
and tip you negative so
is the growth rate sufficiently close to
zero we're getting pretty close to zero
right and then the third condition that
i look at is at least one of my four
coincident indicators has to have
negative growth and coincident i mean
income consumption employment or
production right industrial production
is not quite negative yet employment
growth is is declining but still at
about four percent consumption growth
has fallen to about two percent so it's
not quite zero and then real income is
real income negative it it is about to
be depending on which measure you're
using right and i think i i would argue
that discretionary consumption is is
probably slowing at a faster pace
exactly right is it because of
essentials inflation exactly right my
friend torsten slock at apollo i think
you met torsten recently but my friend
torsten slackett apollo said that when
you add up
uh food energy and utilities costs
pre-ukraine that that was absorbing 50
of your lowest income quintiles
after tax income i mean that's a massive
number massive and and it shows in the
consumer sentiment numbers university of
michigan consumer sentiment numbers
which are plunging to
levels that are quite consistent with
recession i'm always very cautious to
throw the recessionary flag because you
hate to be labeled one of these people
that's throwing recession around lightly
and it's not to be thrown out lightly
which is why i try and map out criteria
which give us a really good indication
that we are at recession's door right
now all you need is a shock
and
are we there yet as of the data in hand
not quite but if the next couple reports
come in as we think they are with this
recent inflation spike from russia
ukraine we will be there so then all you
need is a shock to tip the scales well
two shocks that are pretty historically
common for causing recessions are fed
over tightening and oil price spikes
right those are two very common shocks
so we got both and we have potential
yield curve that is with a 210 spread of
25 basis points exactly before the first
hike right right so so that cocktail
there is uh something that would would
cause uh me to say it's it's a good time
to to manage your risk and that's
ultimately what i try and do i try and
help people manage their risk around
these cyclical inflection points
so a question for both of you i'm
curious um because vance you're going to
have an opinion regardless because
you're as fed up as i am
we're in a midterm election year
oh boy
i'm not gonna ask anything terrible we
don't have to like spend the next 30
minutes talking to elizabeth warren what
fun would that be
um
can the fed go at it alone
if something happens to the markets if
something happens to the economy
and i'm i'm i'm asking both of you the
same question can the fed go out alone
because in a post-covered world the
answer was no
post post-financial crisis the answer
was yes they were able to to bring the
economy back from the brink all by
themselves
my view and it's just an opinion because
unlike you i can't have um i can't come
out publicly with this is what i
fundamentally believe just given my role
in the industry and the compliance
alligators as i like to call them
i suspect that the fed
will very cautiously very slowly try to
get us from
0.25 percent to maybe
two point five percent with a hat tip to
2018
remember the two year was at three
the fed funds rate got to 2.5 what
happened equity markets in q4 crumbled
steve mnuchin our lord and savior came
out on the sunday before christmas and
said don't worry i've talked to the six
largest banks they're all well
capitalized
i wasn't worried steve do i have
something to eat to wear like remember i
thought are you telling this
what's the type like you know you know i
fly a ton yeah that's like a pilot at a
cruising altitude of 37 000 feet clear
blue skies getting on going uh
well folks uh beautiful day out there
i'm really good at crash landings but
you have nothing to worry about
what are you talking about right right
so
you know you and i know some very smart
people who are of the mindset that the
fed is going to have to hike regardless
could the fed hike us into recession
anything's possible i still like to
believe that rainbows butterflies and
unicorns can still exist in harmony
right
but um cue their music in a
mid midterm election year election year
is the fed going to take the political
risk
of doing that
fast forward two years what is this
administration going to want to have uh
in its arsenal when
it's up for election right right and and
i'm not in the business of making
prognostications
um anything is possible you know you
mentioned
um some of these these fat tail events
right um
anything is possible
eric after what we've witnessed yeah
with the biggest stimulus injection into
the us economy that eclipse that of the
new deal of 1940 can the fed go out a
little longer
so
it depends on what on what the objective
is right if preventing a meltdown
i think that the so i don't think that
the fed can really go at this alone but
that doesn't mean that marrying the fed
in the treasury is going to yield
good results right so
can the federal reserve at this point do
anything to help the real economy no and
i think that we all know that the answer
to that question over the last 10 or 15
years has been no right there's been
heavy-handed central banks around the
world and we've produced some of the
worst real growth rates that we've seen
in decades right so can the fed go at it
alone and help the real economy
absolutely not
can the fed go at it alone and help
asset markets potentially right but they
couldn't do it
during the cobit they needed help from
the treasury in terms of these special
purpose vehicles right right
so which pat toomey has said are not
allowed to be not a lot anymore right so
so that is it switches off janet that is
interesting so um but if you do have the
fed in the treasury let's say they don't
do special purpose vehicles but they do
a combination of easier monetary policy
with stimulus which is what most people
think that they'll do at the first sign
of
of a problem uh
yeah i do think that it'll create
another short-term pop but we're seeing
right now
what the
uh aftermath or what the long-term
effects of these heavy-handed government
policies are whether it's from the
federal reserve or the treasury in terms
of high inflation
and lower real income real income
is not any higher than it was before
covid on february of 2020. so that is
america did they help us at all did they
end up help
were these policies helpful when you
know when when uh when you look at the
full sample which usually takes in in my
view in my work about three years of any
of these government policies to show
what the what the full effect was right
we can't we can't look at the stimulus
and then look at the next quarter's
growth right because of course if they
send you a check today you're gonna
spend it right but what was the
impact of that it was a damaged supply
chain higher inflation lower real income
these problems manifest over time
and when you look at the full three-year
sample i don't think that these policies
are ultimately helpful so i don't think
that they can go out alone but even if
they do go out with the treasury i'm not
sure it'll be any helpful to the real
economy
well from somebody who's watched
corporate debt go from 10 trillion to 12
trillion outstanding in a post-covered
world i'll never forget that time stamp
february the 19th
2020 i see this headline that said u.s
corporate debt market surpasses 10
trillion
milestone and now 2 trillion dollars
later
balance sheets aren't any healthier
there's been a lot of equity issued
right
generally speaking we don't have a
healthier corporate bond market and i
learned about that from jeremy stein who
started at the fed with jay powell and
he's like you can only monkey with the
corporate debt market so much before
something's going to break and i would
argue that
i would argue that this fed because it's
so hawkish
the voting members in 2022 i would argue
that that this fed's prepared to put the
u.s economy into recession it may be
their only choice if their goal is to
bring down
inflation because if inflation is
related to
the supply chain and the supply chains
are not getting any better before the
election let's say let's say that's
their goal to bring down inflation
before the election
well if the supply side is permanently
crimped
sort of your only option is to stunt
demand
right
so
this is a box like i've never seen
before in terms of uh what i would
really
not be envious of is is what happens if
these
uh gdp numbers or real growth numbers
come down even further and then it leads
to uh job losses right because now we're
talking about an ultimate like a
legitimate box against their mandate
right because their mandates employment
and price stability so what do you do if
the inflation rate is still six or seven
percent and you have one or two nfp
numbers that are minus a hundred yep now
what that's game changer that's a game
changer and then
if you if you are of the opinion that
the fed likes to uh communicate with the
with the white house on policy which is
which is preferable
job cuts and job losses or higher
inflation what do you pick
it's a very difficult situation that
we're in and i don't think that the fed
has well i mean
it's a unique backdrop to see
politicians saying the fed needs to
tighten policy i'm like going back in my
history books on that
the lens that i look at
the manifestation of this massive sort
of irreparable box
is a two's tens curve that's 25 basis
points before the first hike
i think the bond market is very uh is
picking up on the fact that this is a
sort of a very treacherous situation and
i'm not sure if the bond market's
convinced that they can weasel their way
out of it
no i'm i i think you're right um
and no i don't think the fed has ever
done this much damage to itself or been
by the way as politicized as it is right
i mean we still have all these empty
seats i mean it's just remarkable right
um
vance let's just say some of our younger
viewers are watching today and that
sounded like the biggest cliche of all
time
what do you tell people who are at the
beginning of their investing life cycle
if somebody's like mr bars
how do i how do i get started what's the
first thing that you recommend that i do
research
research research 100
understand
where we are in this cycle which
specific cycle it is
the the difference between macro and
micro understand
you know ultimately
what is their investment objective i
have a lot of people reach out to me and
do a lot of mentorship and i'm not very
public about that
i've been very fortunate to have some
mentors in my career and
we all hit a certain point in our lives
where
we want to give back where we want to
carry that baton right
the world is still full of good despite
you know all of these things that we've
discussed and all the potential concerns
on the horizon
but you know i really when they ask
you know what do i buy
i really identify what is it ultimately
that they want is it the hot stock
because you know what i'm not on cnbc
and i'm not jim cramer right yeah like
i'm sorry
right
but
um
you know it is what type of account is
it what's the time horizon and so forth
and maybe save learn how to save
oh
let me ask why are we not teaching
financial literacy in this country why
is that not part of it
like
seriously
it just boggles my mind
because you actually jumped to
step two i'm trying to get younger
people to understand that they need to
save
they need to save in the first place
it's such an important point i i read a
report that
the amount of money that you have at
retirement
is uh determined 75 percent by your
savings rate
the second factor was not even rate of
return it was what you do i think which
is asset allocation right right
the rate of return that you get on your
investments whether it's five percent or
eight percent is a lot less important
than how much you're able to earn and
how much you're able to save out of that
income so i feel like most people spend
99 of their time focused on the rate of
return and such a small percentage of
the time on
one saving and then two what's my
overall asset allocation strategy what's
my plan and then i can play around the
edges of that plan and try and enhance
the rate of return
you know maybe manage these cycles but
within the context of a broader asset
allocation plan and a high savings rate
100 and coming up with an actual plan
right so if this was triage what are our
immediate cost needs are we saving for a
house are we saving for retirement yep
so many of these folks reach out they're
like i just i want as much money as
possible
where
what are your goals exactly right and
what's the time frame here and so coming
up with different pockets
you know for specific purposes is
important eric
recommended reading if somebody wants to
get started to just begin to understand
the basics of your world
so it's not going to put somebody young
to sleep yeah so
i'll actually start with with a book
that lacy hunt recommended to me as a
starting point which was uh milton and
rose friedman free to choose
and it's a really important point a
really important book because
um
it explains the the changing incentives
that happen when the government steps in
whether it's the federal reserve or uh
the the federal government
and how that changes incentives and it
just gives a very high level overview of
how economies work how incentives work
what moves the world forward what
doesn't move the world forward
and beyond that
i would i would read anything on on
demographics and demographic forecasts
because if there's one thing that you
that it's important to understand would
be would be democracy
okay so i just can we can we possibly
as a parting gift to all the viewers can
you
what's the deal with these socks guys
so
for me these socks are dachshunds
at home i have a four-year-old wire hair
dachshund
who's the cutest guy you'll ever see so
in honor of him today for good luck i i
wore okay so they rock yeah and sure you
mentioned that because normally the
socks that i wear
are either
socks with my daughter's face or my
son's face we have two very young
children as late blooming parents and
they're very cute and well they take
after mom thank goodness um
but you know we live in a in a world
where things are very serious and this
industry can be so you're wearing
bespoke socks yeah you know it's there's
um
it just adds a little
personality well look guys i've never
talked about socks on down the middle um
but that goes to show you that i need to
have more young people on who actually
think about
what well women always think about what
we put on that team but men as well
uh i want to thank both of you this was
so different and unique and i hope the
viewers enjoy it and let's do this again
sometime thank you such an honor yes and
thank you so much for having us thanks
guys
okay so i'm not as old as you thought
right i brought in some people who are
actually hip onto the show so um give me
a big thumbs up
and uh and you know on the theme that
they both agreed on vance and eric
demographics is destiny
if you want the ultimate primer go back
to the down the middle where i
interviewed dennis mcgill of zelman and
associates
and and learn about where we are in the
long cycle of u.s demographics that does
not just touch on the older generations
but indeed
your age much younger generations and
declining population growth in that
cohort as well
until next time i appreciate your time
this is danielle dimartino booth with
down the middle thank you
[Music]